[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
My name is Chelsea
Parlett-Pelleriti,
and I'm on Twitter
@ChelseaParlett in case
you want to follow any of the
fun stats content that I make.
And speaking of stats
content, something
that I've spent a lot of
time making in the past year
are guided simulation exercises.
I teach data science to
mostly undergraduates,
and it can be an
intimidating subject to them.
I often get asked
for "rules of thumb"
that they can use to make
good data science decisions.
And while there are
some rules of thumb
that work in a
lot of situations,
I want my students to come
away with a deep understanding
of the concepts so when
they're in a situation where
that rule of thumb doesn't
apply, they're not just stuck.
I decided that guided simulation
exercises were a great way
to create that
deeper understanding.
By my definition, guided
simulation exercises
are activities where you're
asked to simulate data,
you apply an algorithm or
a computation to that data.
And then you're
given specific guided
questions that can
help you figure out
what that simulation
can tell you
about whichever
algorithm or computation
you applied to the data.
Simulation exercises are
helpful for three main reasons.
First, I think it encourages
this attitude of exploration
when learning.
And second, it gives you
tools to test your intuition
or try weird edge cases that you
think of and see what happens.
And finally, I think it
empowers this deep understanding
of the concepts that
you're learning.
A lot of people
learn data science
because they think they should.
But my goal is to help
people really deeply explore
the concepts that
they're learning.
And sure they could write
their own simulations,
but I think the guided
part is really important.
I think these exercises
are a little more
practical than just
throwing people
in the deep end on their own.
It makes simulating data in
R feel more approachable,
and it gives people tools
to try and figure things
out themselves rather than just
relying on what they're told.
Relatedly, the guided
nature of these exercises
gives people the tools to learn
and try things on their own
and tailor their experience
to things that specifically
make them curious.
For example, maybe
you're wondering
what would happen if I
ran principal component
analysis on a set
of variables that
are completely uncorrelated?
We'll try it out.
Or maybe you're wondering
why we would ever
use k-fold cross-validation
rather than the simpler
and more computationally
efficient train test split?
Well run a bunch of simulations
and see what the difference is.
In my opinion, the
best data scientists
are the ones who have a
little bit of doubt about
whether the established method
is the best way necessarily.
And these guided
simulation exercises
encourage people
to test things out,
to push on the boundaries
of established methods,
and to figure out how our
favorite algorithms work
in atypical situations.
After all, our data will
not always be well behaved.
Guided simulation
exercises are not
a replacement for
the math in theory
that go behind data
science topics,
but it can help support them.
And I think the examples,
the specific questions,
and the established code
help make simulation
more accessible,
especially to people
who don't have the
skills yet or maybe don't
have the time to set all
of that up on their own.
I hope you'll check out
the guided simulations that
are already on the conference
GitHub and all of the ones
that we make in the future.
But for now, in
my last minute, I
would love to give you
the world's quickest
overview of my principal
component analysis guided
simulation exercise.
When I teach principal
component analysis,
one of the main ideas
that I emphasize
is that principal component
analysis takes advantage
of relationships
between variables
in order to create more
efficient axes that
better define the
variation in the data.
So it shouldn't be
a surprise that when
we look at principal component
analysis on completely
uncorrelated variables,
the screeplot shows us
that each variable
pretty much contributes
its own independent information.
On the other hand, when we have
highly correlated variables,
the PCA model as well
as the screeplot
tells us that a lot
of the variation
then can be explained
by one single component
because there is a lot of
shared information in the data
originally.
Thank you so much for
listening to my talk.
I would love to connect with
all of you over the internet
and hear whether you use any
of these guided simulation
exercises, either for yourself
or for people that you teach.
And definitely let me know if
you create any of your own.
I would love to
hear about it think.
[MUSIC PLAYING]